[Music]
ryan i want to hear about your burning
man experience as our next talk about a
bull so you spent some time
yeah out in the desert oh my goodness
yeah inhaling
dust and dirt and uh black rock city
tell me about it yeah man uh i'll tell
you what i could tell you in five
minutes um
if you ask you know a hundred people
from burning man like hey what is
burning man you're gonna get a hundred
different answers you might get a
thousand different answers if you ask a
thousand different people
um but all i can say is like you you
think you know what it's gonna be
you look at instagram you
read blogs you you know you do all the
research you prepare as much as you can
and then
nothing can prepare you for your first
burning man experience because it's like
it's everything it's it's uh
it's um i don't know just imagine
everything that humanity has to offer
it's all right there
and everyone is there to um provide that
for each other
and that's what really attracted me to
go was this
giving community
of 80 000 people
i mean what is not uh appealing about
that like i gotta check this out and i'm
glad i did it was freaking awesome i can
tell you about like
i don't know man like some of the
biggest things i got from it
um which is interesting because i went
there expecting to to give a little bit
but mostly wanted to like you know i
wanted to maybe have like a spiritual
experience or
different perspective on things and i
did get those things
but that was like 10 or 20 of it i ended
up um
giving a lot to to uh
yeah to just different people man i mean
just um you know how i love to make new
friends everywhere i go yes indeed and
it's very easy to do that at burning man
and i made some amazing connections and
uh what i realized one of the things i
realized about burning man is um
well you know how i always kind of
mention that we're all processing trauma
every single one of us man in a burning
man that's what they're doing they are
they're going there to release i mean
that's the whole thing of burning the
man down is is this release letting go
and um i was able to like really help
people let go of some of their traumas
um during the week and it was like
it just felt so good man because you
know i'd love to give advice yeah yeah
josh and i made a living out of it we
all three made a living out of it but
sometimes i'm like oh you know i'm like
i give too much advice i give too much
advice but like a burning man like
people were just like starving for like
a different perspective and i was able
to do that a lot man i mean it was it
was incredible um give an example of one
way that you contributed to someone
oh yeah i mean real quick like i met one
gentleman uh we were waiting in line to
get some cider and uh
i i you know within the first 30 seconds
you know he had mentioned to me that
like he doesn't talk to his dad
and um
you know i kind of i can relate with
that and so i just talked to him about
relationship with my parents and kind of
things that i've been able to help
myself overcome with them and have a
deeper relationship with them and the
biggest thing was you know hey man um
you know you've got your parents like i
understand that you feel like
they owe you something but they don't
owe you anything
and
if you want your parents to like really
respect your battles like you have to
respect theirs first and that sucks
because it's almost like you have to be
their parent
and um
you would have thought i would have
given them like the winning lottery
numbers or something i mean like like he
started tearing up it was it was amazing
it was beautiful
let me tell you the biggest thing i got
out of this though so there are these
ten principles with um
with burning man and one like it's oh
yeah i've heard about this yeah so it's
like radical expression
radical self-reliance i'm only going the
ones i remember i don't remember all
right one of them is radical inclusion
though okay
and that's what's cool about burning man
is you can go there you can do whatever
you want you can release whatever you
want to release you can
dress however you want
you can be yourself 100
and you will feel included
so
we go to this venue
um to listen to some music and i'm with
some of these uh
people from my camp and um they're all
they're all over 50. like they're all
you know some older folks
and um we're having a blast we're just
kind of you know
laughing and dancing and then all of a
sudden on the other side of the dance
floor
i see this dude waving
it's huge let's go brandon flag
let's go brandon
i'm record man
i am instantly like
this is about inclusion this doesn't
feel like inclusion to me no it's not
this feels like separation yes and so i
look over at one of my campaigns i'm
like can you believe this and like we
start feeding off each other
and then it hits me
radical inclusion
and i look at my camp man i'm like how
dare us
he's like what do you mean
i'm like we can't pick and choose what
we want to include like if we want to do
radical inclusion we have to include
everybody it doesn't mean you agree with
them it doesn't mean you think that
they're morally right it doesn't mean
that you think that they're living their
life the right way but you can at least
make them feel included yeah and that's
a great first step so
i go from anger
to like
um
i go from anger to
um
this realization to like
letting go and then and now i got to
push through now i'm like i got to push
through this judgment that i have
so i look at my camp man i'm like i'm
going to go over and give this dude a
hug
she was like what
and i'm like i'm embracing it i was like
i'm pushing this is so uncomfortable for
me like i'm i'm pushing through this
she's like you know what that's
that's a good idea so
i head on over there
dude just like waving he's like dancing
waving his flag
and uh i go up to him i'm like hey man
i'm so glad you're here he's like thank
you man i appreciate that
are you having a good time he's like
yeah i'm having a blast man waving his
flag high
i said are you hugging he's like yeah i
am hugging
bring it in man so i go up to give him a
hug
i'm like hey man my name's ryan what's
your name
brandon
it was so it was the best lesson i ever
had in my life
it was so i went from like angry to
release to like pushing through
discomfort to like i could not stop
laughing i'm like this guy's a genius
it was so good man it was um that was
just one of the many many experiences
and i could i could give you 10 more but
i heard the bell like three minutes ago
so i'm gonna let it go did you enjoy
this stand-alone patreon highlight if so
you can listen to full episodes of the
minimalists private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free